I love your outfit I asked her if she
did a get ready video like coming out
here okay okay I cannot wait to see this
so you have 6 million followers yes
that's incredible okay so explain get
ready with me did that just you were
just doing it for fun and then it ended
up becoming like a segment almost yeah
so on Tik Tok you can do like a live
stream video and I would always do those
before I was going out and those videos
would get like way more views in way
more traction than my oh oh my gosh
there you are crazy they would get more
views than the videos I was posting on
Tik Tok so I was like you know what why
don't I just like turn these like
getting ready videos into a Tik Tok
video and they just like took off um
it's crazy to me I guess people are just
like interested and I do my makeup while
I'm kind of talking about like where I'm
going or what's going on and a lot of it
would be like me at the University of
Miami like night life in Miami what is
Miami like and I think it's just like a
crazy Universe of down in Miami so
people were just like so interested in
it yeah and and took off from there I
like though when you I think breaking
down the wall that's the reason why
people get into it as well because
people like to see people that are
relatable I think yeah yeah um well one
of Alex's get ready with me post that
went viral oh this is amazing was her
getting ready for a Miami Dolphins game
so let's see that I love it I have this
tiny little Jimmy chew bag which I think
goes with the heels feel like a mom
picking up her kids from school
we
I'm like okay I love that you think a
mom could look like that together
picking up I know it is amazing but so
the mom the moms came they came out
right the moms humbled me very quickly
they were like girl yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah this is on the way to school this
is this is them on
the okay so this is me after yeah yes
yeah this is
you this
is this is me this is after sleeping
with your children and they they kick
you all night and it's super fun no I my
goal is to look like you in that video
at some point so wait so you have a new
podcast this is like a new realm for you
so like do you like it are you enjoying
I love it it's been a learning process
for sure I you know cuz when you're
talking for 2 minutes in a Tik Tok video
and now I'm talking for 2 hours for you
know one episode to come out it's very
different and I think people are getting
to see like a different side of me or
just learning so much about me that they
didn't know before and I mean there's
many more stories to come we're only
does it stress you to be that vulnerable
does it because it's a little more in
depth I feel like the podcast yeah so
right before I launched the first
episode I was freaking out I was like I
don't think I can do this like I'm so
stressed because the more you tell
people the more room there is for
criticism and stuff but but the reason I
feel comfortable with like sharing my
life online is just that I feel like I'm
kind of directing The Narrative of it
and like I'm okay with people not liking
me if they don't like who you actually I
am yeah it's a little bit more
frustrating when there's like false
stuff out there and then I'm like it's
so frustrating but um it's important to
me to kind of help like the younger
audience that's watching me too like I
wish I had someone who was like kind of
you know showing their acne or telling
about like getting cheated on you know
all that stuff to like look up to when I
was younger so I and to connect to yeah
yeah hopefully setting a good example
yeah well good luck with it six episodes
in that's really awesome thank you yeah
it is a lot of work I heard that's why I
don't want to do one um but we did the
math though and um during the course of
just this segment Al Alex has gained
over 5,000 followers so just just now
that just happened it's amazing let's do
a commercial break everybody you can
listen to hot mess with Alex Earl every
Thursday on
[Music]
[Applause]
Spotify thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home